I really wish that the level of
frustration I am currently feeling was
not so dang familiar so normally today
would have been a doctor who related
video but I have got to get this off my
chest because otherwise it's gonna
fester in my head and I don't need this
nonsense weighing down my holidays I
need to talk about JK Rowling and the
fact that yes yes she is in fact
transphobic but before we get into that
let's back up and add a bunch of
qualifiers and footnotes to that
Proclamation I debated whether or not I
was going to do this video at all
because I try very hard to not talk
about the personal views or actions of
writers actors or directors or any of
the creators unless it in some way is
tied to their works since that is what I
care about first and foremost it's why I
did a video on Gareth Edwards and not
say Trisha Paytas because the Edwards
story directly tied into Doctor Who and
Paytas was nothing but drama that in no
way related to the things that I prefer
to actually focus on and this issue of
Rowling does really kind of ride the
line because strictly speaking what I'm
going to be talking about doesn't
directly tie into Harry Potter or the
Wizarding World franchises in any
immediate way and part of me would
really rather leave it some folks have
even asked quite fairly why would I
follow this stuff if it bothers me like
it does and I should be clear I do not
seek this stuff out I don't enjoy
real-life drama I don't see it as any
kind of entertainment it causes me
stress but if and when drama like this
is related to what I enjoy well it tends
to show up on my radar regardless and if
you were on Twitter at all over the last
few days this was kind of hard to miss
right up there with Star Wars spoilers
now I don't actually follow Miz rolling
you know it's not like I've been waiting
for this to happen I've been watching
out for it and I would love to not care
but now that I know I can't shut off the
bit of my brain that is decided is going
to latch on to this it may be a weird
comparison but it's not dissimilar to
why I hate it when movie trailers show
anything from further into the movie
than the halfway mark because I'll be
trying to enjoy the movie and a sliver
of my brain will keep needling me hey
hey haven't seen this bit yet remember
that from the trailer think it's coming
soon when do you think it'll be here huh
huh huh once I know a thing I can't just
pretend that I don't and one more note
before we dig into this there are two
words that I won't be using to refer to
Miz rollin Pickett and turf not because
I do or don't think either one applies
but because as clickbait Diaz they are
both terms tend to derail the
conversation that I actually want to try
and have because people will splinter
off into arguments about what degree of
prejudicial behavior is needed in order
to fairly apply the word bigot and
whether or not turf is a slur and I
would rather just really not weed be
either of those right now so I'm going
to be using the word transphobic which
will still piss some folks off but I
mean what can you do oh and by the way
transphobia is a blanket term that
doesn't strictly refer to fear the way
most people think of phobia it covers a
wide range of matters in behavior and
beliefs is that include but are not
limited to a version anger hatred
violence diminishment and negation okay
so thanks for recent events I've had to
come to terms with the idea that ms
Rowling author of the Harry Potter
franchise is in fact transphobic but
there are plenty people who have been
saying that for a while now so before I
dive into the thing that finally tipped
the scale for me personally we should do
a quick recap with the understanding
that my research abilities are not
amazing and
this will not be comprehensive it's just
the best that I could do and is how I
came to where I am right now so it looks
like trouble started brewing for rolling
on this front in 2017 when her official
Twitter liked a tweet promoting a
transphobic online article I wasn't able
to find if rolling or her
representatives ever respond responded
to the the criticisms of this particular
incidents but something very similar
happened the next year when she liked to
tweet which referred to trans women as
men in dresses now this one I did find a
response to and rolling his
representatives claimed that she'd done
it by accident because she'd been
holding the phone incorrectly this
explanation
couldn't really be applied when earlier
this year she began to follow an openly
transphobic youtuber named Magdalena
burns now Byrnes passed away from brain
cancer several months ago so out of
respect and also staying on topic I'm
not really gonna dig into her just know
that nobody has ever claimed that burns
wasn't openly against transgender as an
identity
so when Rowling started following her
this time her representatives took a
different angle and noted that following
is not the same as endorsing which is
true hate follows are apparently a thing
I don't get it but there you go
however note that neither Rowling nor
her EPS ever denounced any of these
views or actually said that she
disagreed with him they only said this
isn't proof that she agrees there's also
been some re-examination of a
transgender character from her 2014
novel the silkworm but I haven't read it
and I also couldn't find a proper
breakdown of that particular character
from a source that I felt totally
confident in so I'm not gonna make a
call as to whether or not the character
and the characters used was problematic
just know that the plot summaries I
found looked like they could have gone
badly very much depending on the
execution and there was some criticism
on this particular point so that's in
the mix - there's your background and as
I said this wasn't enough
for me to declare rolling a transphobia
in the past I've never been a defender
of hers and I've openly criticized her
on other issues some might even say
related ones but this particular one
felt murky enough to me that I was
comfortable with myself just setting all
of it aside as best as I could I mean
you can go back to any critical video
that I've made on Harry Potter or MS
Rowling herself I've never touched on
this criticism of her before even though
it's not new so let's bring it up to the
present where ms Rowling tweeted her
support of a woman named Maya for stater
Forsett er was a tax expert for a think
tank who was let go for publicly voicing
her hardline views on gender which
basically boiled down to men are men
women are women nobody can change what
they were born as the only precise quote
that I found was men cannot change into
women because there was only so far down
this rabbit hole I was prepared to go to
get her exact words but much like with
burns no Matt nobody appears to be
arguing that four Sator isn't
transphobic including the woman herself
instead the debate has been over whether
or not she should have lost her job this
came up in the news cycle because
earlier this week the central London
employment tribunal ruled against her
and said that her dismissal was fair in
their view now I don't know exactly how
this tribunal works but from what I
understand it's not technically a legal
entity but it has statutory jurisdiction
to settle disputes between employers and
employees so she lost the case that was
before them be basically because of how
unambiguous her stance was now to use
the exact words from the judgment that
was issued the judge said I conclude
from the totality of the evidence that
she is absolutist in her view of sex and
it is a core component of her belief
that she will refer to a person by the
sex she considered appropriate even if
it violates their dignity and/or creates
an intimidating
hostile degrading humiliating or
offensive environment in other words
it's not just that force that are held
transphobic beliefs is that she was so
committed to them that she was prepared
to willfully create a hostile work
environment and the judge felt it was
clear she would not adjust her behavior
and therefore the company was within
their rights to let her go
so that's Maya force center and as one
might expect this ruling sparked online
debate and a hashtag the hashtag was I
stand with mine so now we finally get to
bring in ms Rowling so on December 19th
she tweeted quote dress however you
please call yourself whatever you like
sleep with any consulting consenting
adult who will have you live your best
life in peace and security but force
women out of their jobs for stating that
sex is real hashtag I stand with my
hashtag this is not a drill so unlike
the earlier twitter twitter issues that
I've mentioned this isn't alike this
isn't a follow these are her words
openly and plainly voicing her support
for a woman removed from her job for
reasons tied to that woman's harshly
transphobic views now no doubt some
folks are going to point out that
Rowling says in that very tweet people
can still dress and call themselves what
they like what's the problem she can't
be transphobic if that's what she's
saying and I have neither the time nor
the inclination to explain why this view
while vastly preferable to open
hostility is still a low-key form of
transphobia so instead if you're unclear
on that particular point I would
recommend a fantastic video on the
subject from philosophy tube because he
explains it better than I could
anyways in digging into this I also
tried to see what I could find
as far as counter points in Rowling's
favor and came up with very little I
found two prominently cited instances
that roley's defenders claim show she's
actually an ally the first dates from
2014 when a Harry
a fan asked her over Twitter if there
were LGBTQ students at Hogwarts which
Rowling responded to by saying but of
course and shared an image that read if
Harry Potter taught us anything is that
no one should live in a closet this
sounds good but is weakened by the fact
that Rowling has a decade-long history
of claiming LGBTQ or at least gay men
exist in the Wizarding World while
offering no concrete proof of this in
any of the actual works and it's not
really a proclamation of support so much
it as it is a oh yeah sure that works
response to a fan question the other
thing I found was in 2017 Rowling did a
pretty epic job of dunking on Tommy
Lauren's defense of the Trump
administration when that administration
implemented a ban on trans people
serving in the military Lauren had gone
off on a tangent about Trump defending
the u.s. from terrorists and she also
tossed in some digs about Obama while
she was at it - which Rowling responded
truly who amongst us can forget Trump
ordering the killing of bin Laden or
Obama bragging about barging in on naked
beauty contestants now that is a pretty
spicy burn however if you look at it
closely nowhere does Rowling actually
defend trans servicepeople or even
attack the military ban in specific yes
that was the topic that got Lawrence
started but Rowling only went after the
hypocrisy not the policy and that's
pretty much how I ended up where I am
and I am prepared to cop that it might
be true that no single incident I've
talked about is enough to call our
transphobic but to pick apart each piece
of evidence one by one is to ignore the
fact that we now have repeated incidents
all pointing to the same conclusion and
the few things I could find that people
say point to any other conclusion are in
truth worded in such a way as to not
actually contradict
a transphobic viewpoint by now
Rowling and her reps both know that this
is an ongoing issue and they've only
ever gone on the defensive when it comes
up not once that I could find has
Rowling flatly stated her own beliefs on
the subject of transgender identity and
some might say that means we can't for
say say for sure she's transphobic but
if she isn't if she truly doesn't
believe any of these things then why
won't she say that she is not a
politically private person she has
donated to political parties plainly
stated her views on political figures
and issues from Trump to Briggs it's
Scottish independence the conflict in
Israel she's happy to make clear her
views on these issues but she won't say
what she believes on this one
despite the blunders she's not unsaved
when it comes to public relations at
this point there will be no real benefit
to remaining silent unless she knows
that the views she holds aren't the ones
her liberal leaning fan base want to
hear now that is admittedly speculative
on my part but her refusal to denounce
these views leaves me with little else
that I can do as far as a conclusion
goes all I can do at this point is look
at what's happened she's given social
media support to transphobic views and
individuals and amplified their messages
and beliefs by supporting them on her
platform I have not been able to find
any instance of her granting a similar
boost or platform for trans rights and
the best I've been able to find were
statements that implied support but
never actually said it much like how she
writes the supposedly gay character of
Dumbledore come to think of it all of
this points me to the conclusion that
Rowling shares the transphobic views
she's repeatedly given support to but is
just self-aware enough to realize that
saying those things herself is a bad
idea and if you have evidence that I
missed that paints a better picture I
hope
you will share it with me because I am
not happy about coming to this
conclusion part of the reason I'm making
this video is to contain in one place my
feelings on this because I don't intend
to have this enter into my talking about
Harry Potter or fantastic beasts I'm
still gonna do a ranking video of the
movies I'm still considering doing a
video on the curse child I'm going to
keep continue reading these books to my
daughter at bedtime and I don't plan to
bring up any of this in relation to
those things we'll see how I feel about
things when the next fantastic Beast
movie comes out because that will put me
in a situation of potentially
financially supporting a woman with
views in opposition of people like me
and I can't say at this point if I'll be
okay with doing that or not but all the
other stuff I've already paid for the
movies the books my Slytherin gear I'm
not getting getting rid of any of it
because I still love these things and
they're mine nobody not and not even the
author gets to take them away from me to
end on a more positive note and in case
anybody out there is looking for a
comparative for how to handle this kind
of thing if you don't hold to those
transphobic views actress Beibei Newerth
liked Rowling's tweet supporting for
stater because unless you know what the
hashtag was about which she didn't at
first it's easy to miss what's going on
from the words alone but as soon as it
was pointed out to her she tweeted I
totally misunderstood someone's tweet
today and liked it it's been explained
to me that her comment was transphobic
and now I'm horrified that I liked it I
assure you I misread / misunderstood her
intent I've of course unliked it sorry
and that is how you do it respond
quickly apologize genuinely offer an
explanation it's not that hard and fun
bonus when I retweeted this and added my
comment praising her handling of it she
replied so yeah
new favorite celebrity on Twitter thank
you for saying all the way through
through this little personal therapy
session I encourage you to leave a
comment even if you disagree just do it
respectfully and of course like
subscribe share this video consider
supporting me on patreon but you also
don't have to do any of that because at
the end of the day you are the council
and I just running the meetings and
until next time this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]